Portland Trailblazers a possible
destination maybe for Carmelo Anthony of
the New York Knicks talk about that more
it's pretty Damian Lillard the Portland
Trail Blazers guard he's working with
Powerade and he power your school
program which will award 1 million to
high school athletic programs around the
country and Damian joins me here on the
show Damian the last time you talked to
or texted with Carmelo Anthony was when
last week would you say what state I
just checked on the situation that I
have been hearing about Missy Hawk I
could improve my team so to get a guy
like Carmelo he would have to waive that
no trade clause
what was your recruiting pitch for
Carmela to do that I wasn't really a
pitch I just reached out to him and I
let him know that the answer just wasn't
from our front office influence a
possibility and there was definitely
interest from the players as well and I
didn't want that to be confused so there
was I didn't put no pressure on them
whereas we watch the questions I just
said what it was from our hands did you
get any kind of sense that he would be
willing to waive that no trade clause I
mean I didn't get a sense that he
wouldn't okay go
what we have is a good situation for him
that's kind of where I went I just you
know let him know what I thought he
could do for our team and what I came to
do with his presence and I was it you
know we didn't go over those details and
talk about a no-trade clause or anything
like that you know he's going to make
his own decision to do that or not
and I just want to make sure that we had
some kind of conversation what would a
guy from New York like Carmelo Anthony
like about the city of Portland oh when
I think important we people talk about
what it would be like a Portland or what
it is like in Portland but having
actually lived here and you know I live
here year-round so I know it's a great
like to live some of the best food in
the United States the way you talk about
loving a game of basketball
some our soccer team is all that the
city has so we get a lot of support you
know our fans really back on cam and
passionate about our team so that type
of environment in that type of love and
support around the city what what NBA
player wouldn't want to be a part of it
with Carmelo Anthony
the Blazers are what in the Western
Conference next season
let's go Jane top two top three I don't
know how they were a top team you add if
you add in our roster is it the
landscape that it is Damian you almost
have to keep fighting for as many
superstars you can get to try to keep up
with Golden State I think it is more
about fit you got to add players to your
king that that fit with your team and I
can make your team a better team and
that's not always superstars dr. Damon
lo the Portland Trail Blazers guard
worked with power oddity power your
school program joining us here Dan
Patrick show when you guys picked up use
of Newark itch Damian you went 14 and
six with him on the team that's a
winning percentage I believe right
around 70% is that the type of team that
with or without Carmelo Anthony you guys
are next season I think so
I think when we added in we became much
better team just having the low post
presence god I could make plays out of
the pick and roll when you see high
roller god I can protect the rim on the
defensive end and a guy would knew like
you know he brought something talking
that we hadn't had four for two years
and it wasn't just the five or six game
over the last 20 20 or so games of the
season and there was a steady
performance from him so I think you you
add him to our team for a fourth season
with that much better I think we had him
last year we have 50 plus 20
[Music]
you know so as people forget about that
part but I think going into next season
we're I think will be better than what
people expect us to be were you
surprised
he had that type of impact he had a news
is right and even in the one game that
he played in the playoffs I think it was
it was more evident than ever you're
working I mentioned with Powerade to
power your school program I will award 1
million to high school athletic programs
around the country tell me what you're
doing with that all this program is
going to allow a lot of the young
athletes from 500 schools to submit
essays written or through video to try
to be a part of it and coming from the
type of city that I come from and being
in their shoes one before you know I
want to be a part of it and it's really
important so Polycom is where they
submit the videos or they submit the
essays and you know all the videos would
be watched and they will get read just
to see who comes across with the
strongest message or who's going to be a
program 500 schools if we talk again in
November is Carmelo Anthony on your team
oh so who is a who's a better recruiter
you are CJ McCollum I'm not sure we
haven't landed any other the superstars
I guess or maybe we're neither one of us
is that good every crew well good luck
with everything Damian both with the
recruiting of players and of course this
power a power your school program thanks
taking a few minutes to join me here on
the show thank you that's Damian Lillard
Portland Trail Blazers guard joining me
here Dan Patrick show the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience